merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à monsieur christian estrosi
monsieur le premier ministre
nul n'a donner de leçon de dignité
alors que le président de la république
il vous plaît allez a enfin reconnu que
la france était en guerre depuis
longtemps contre l'état islamique tant à
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur nous devons
avant tout partager l'immense chagrin de
notre peuple en pensant à toutes ces
victimes innocentes et l'infini colère
que notre nation exprime avec dignité
ici et là nous saluons que soit enfin
retenu un certain nombre de propositions
qui si même nous avons suggéré depuis de
si longs mois et que nous soutiendrons
pourquoi si tard pourquoi tant de sang
versé tant de larmes pour que vous nous
entendent y ait deux exemples voilà des
mois
allez que nous avons demandé la mise
hors d'état de nuire des sympathisants
terroriste ficher véritable bombe
ambulante laissé en liberté
cette proposition brocardé hier devient
donc acceptable pour vous suite à la
tentative d'attentât du thalys j'ai
proposé la mise en place de portiques de
sécurité dans les gares pour contrôler
les accès chez vous on m'a répondu
inapplicable vous plaçant ainsi en
harmonie avec une députée d'extrême
droite qui disait stupide je me félicite
d'avoir entendu aujourd'hui madame royal
plaidé pour cette mesure au delà des
annonces nous vous demandons d'aller
plus vite
contrôles aux frontières bracelet
électronique isolement renvoi des
prêcheurs de haine et fermeture de tous
les lieux salafistes en évitant tout
amalgame entre communautés musulmane et
terroristes islamistes
monsieur le premier ministre c'est sans
attendre que vous pouvez prendre ces
mesures par décret ou par ordonnance
pour qu'elle soit applicable sans délai
y êtes vous prêts dire qu'on est en
guerre c'est la faire tout de suite
merci la parole et à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le monsieur le député estrosi
dans votre question il y a plusieurs
propositions qui doit faire l'objet dès
lors que on considère qu'elles sont
susceptibles d'être mises en oeuvre d'un
examen extrêmement précis concernant
leur faisabilité juridique d'abord
évolué de préciser ce qu'est une fiche
est ce une fiche est ce n'est pas une
fiche qui désigne des individus qui ont
commis des infractions pénales ce n'est
pas une fiche de surveillance ce n'est
pas une fiche de culte culpabilité une
fiche s dans le droit français
c'est une fiche de mise en attention qui
permet aux services de suivre plus
particulièrement un certain nombre de
personnes et de déclencher su ces
personnes si c'est nécessaire des
interceptions de sécurité ou des
dispositifs de surveillance particulier
ce que je dis là n'est rien d'autre que
l'état du droit et si nous voulons dans
la république
combattre le terrorisme nous nous
pensons qu'il faut le faire dans le
respect scrupuleux du droit
et si le droit ne permet pas d'atteindre
l'objectif
alors il faut le changer et c'est ce que
le président de la république a proposé
de ferrières et il n'y a pas de
possibilité d'être efficace dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme
s'il n'y a pas cette exigence
républicaine de l'égalité et de rigueur
intellectuelle
c'est la seule chose que je vous dis
deuxièmement vous avez proposé de mettre
sous bracelet électronique
ceux qui ont une fiche s c'est tout
simplement impossible compte tenu de ce
qu'est et l'article 66 de la
constitution c'est une réalité tous les
constitutionnalistes le reconnaissent
vous avez fait une proposition c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons proposé
au conseil d'état de l'examiner parce
que nous sommes dans le souci de prendre
en compte toutes les propositions pour
ce qui concerne les sections la sécurité
dans les transports en commun nous avons
pris des dispositions précises pour ce
qui concerne la sécurité dans les
transports en commun c'est la
proposition de loi
et ça m'arrive t elle sera relayée dans
les meilleures règles hausse